[Music]
i went to college because i wanted to be
a golf bro
and i was offered a partial golf
scholarship to go to uw stevens point
university wisconsin at stevens point
and i went up there
this would have been the fall of 1987
and i started playing on the golf team
about midway through that fall season
we had a weekend off and i went back to
madison wisconsin and i happened upon a
a bunch of players one guy was named
steve stricker
he's been on the pga tour for years one
is jerry kelly
these are guys i played against in high
school they were a few years in front of
me
steve went to university of illinois
jerry kelly went to hartford to play
play hockey and golf and then they both
made a ton of money later
but
it was really a hard lesson because i
watched them on the driving range
and i said wow these guys are really a
lot better than me i
didn't realize they were that much
better than me but but you know
practicing confirmation bias i said but
i'm better than them around the greens
so you know when the scores come out
we're gonna i'm gonna show them
you know they went out in the morning i
went out in the afternoon and saw the
scores and they were just a lot better
than me and i ended up doing a bunch of
data crunching
and i realized that everything i was
told as a kid because remember i grew up
in wisconsin and that's vince lombardi
country and vince lombardi is a
venerable coach of the green bay packers
when people win the super bowl
the trophy is called the lombardi trophy
so i was raised in the shadows of vince
lombardi who famously said
winners never quit
and quitters never win
so and my parents taught me that time
and time again johnny you you have grit
you stick with it so it was really hard
for me to say
that dream is done i'm gonna have to
quit that i'm gonna fulfill the golf
scholarship and i went and played and
and i had a very successful college golf
career
but from that day on my dream was to
become an economist
and and i could i was still gonna invest
in golf but it wasn't going to be all in
on golf it's going to be all in on golf
and all in
on an econ
and learning about economics and how i
can use it as a trade when i quote grow
up
but but for me
what i see in the business world and in
government
is that people don't quit enough
they don't quit enough because
they've been taught not to quit
they also don't quit enough because they
don't understand or appreciate
the opportunity cost of time
you know when you think about the person
who
moves
to a different job
or they move to
a different apartment
nearly every time they're doing it
because something bad happened in the
workplace or something bad happened in
the apartment
that's all well and fine but you should
also be moving
when you get better opportunities
and you should always be looking at your
opportunity set
we don't do that we don't look at our
opportunities
until our own lot in life is soiled
and that's too late most of the time
because a lot of opportunities have come
and gone so that's called opportunity
cost because we don't realize that if
i'm working on this idea with all of my
might
that there's an idea out there that i
can't work on
and we tend to neglect
that opportunity cost of time
so
we we did this large scale experiment i
helped steve levitt design it and run it
that had people flip a coin
and if it comes up heads you know they
had a tough decision in life whether it
was a job a relationship an apartment
whatever
if it came up heads they need to change
if it comes up tails they don't
in our freakonomics experiment and what
you find is when you track them over
time is that most of the people are much
happier that they made the change
so they didn't realize that there were
greener pastures out there until they
were sort of forced to do it
so that's the optimal quitting chapter
and the reason why again people don't
like to say the q word
so what i say is call an audible
right we we always call an audible in
football we always pivot when people
pivot or call an audible in football
they're glorified
but when you say i'm quitting you're
chastised so i i think part of this is
just reframing
when you quit and we should understand
that it's pivoting or calling an audible
in your life that's the optimal quitting
chapter
how would you
give a pep talk to someone could be a
ceo it could be a student could be
anyone really
who's dealing with let's just call it
a data set
or just a life experience
that it that is not
black and white
and not to imply that your experience is
black and white but if you
if you go into the gym for basketball
practice and you're standing next to
michael jordan you're like okay
there's not much debate here at some
point like that is just a superior
player
and maybe i should choose a game where i
can be number one or number two or
something like that
there are many life circumstances or
business circumstances where it's kind
of a or appears to be like a 51 49 type
of situation and they're like well maybe
if we continue to split test and iterate
and you know i've read all these success
stories could be survivorship bias but
nonetheless you know there are early
studies of like pivot pivot pivot and
then oh my god now you have twitter yeah
what do you say to those people or uh
can you think of a real world example
where it was it was tougher to kind of
determine whether to quit or not no
you're right you're right in in many
cases
we we sort of have these tweeners
where
you know the idea shows some
[Music]
signs you know and
and just enough to keep me going yeah
and the job the job shows some promise
just enough to kind of keep me going
so i i always say that you don't want to
quit
unless you know you have a good option
to go to
so and and that means that you should
periodically say once a month
look at your options and and make sure
that the option is real
and also make sure that it
is along the lines of your comparative
advantage
so there not only needs to be something
that you can go to that's something
exists but also a comparative advantage
is what are you good at
and what are you passionate about doing
the long run
is filled with success
only if you can wake up every morning
and be passionate about something that
you're good at
that's your comparative advantage so i
would say never move or rotate
unless you know that what you're
rotating to you're good at and you're
going to love and also that it's a real
option
otherwise there's no reason just
quitting to quit i i think that
there are a lot of tweener cases where
it could still work out
the problem is is that every time the
olympics comes when this is aired the
olympics will be on
and there will be a story every night
about the person who persevered
the person who had to go and work at the
grocery store and then they drove in the
forklift in the in the basement of
cheese factory
and lo and behold that person has become
a great bobsledder yeah and then the mom
is on there saying i love johnny
and the dad is on there saying how we
knew johnny would never quit and these
are great feel-good stories
and that causes us
to want to persevere
but where is the story
for the billions of people
who went down the hole and they kept
going down the same hole every day
to a mine that had no
gold in it
where is that story written yeah i've
never read one so we don't realize that
there are billions of people who have
tried and tried and tried but they keep
hitting their head against the same wall
and they never succeeded
that's lost opportunity right there
you